oh it's not sparklers it is an anal
thermometer hi I'm Le measer hey I'm
Robbie ml I'm Michael hitchcok I'm
Veronica soosa I'm Catherine Greenwood
I'm Steven H and we're the
cast today we are playing white elephant
or the gift stealing game how it's going
to work is somebody's going to take a
number they're going to choose a gift
they're going to open it the next
person's going to either choose to steal
that gift or open another present one
please just one also if you touch the
gift it's yours there's no shaking it to
hear it who's number one I am St you're
the lucky one you get to pick the gift
first I want the green
one eight colors in one device oh the
original light bowl well looks like
Steven's out of the game a toilet light
I don't mind toilet lights wa no it's a
toilet it's a toilet light a toilet
light I don't understand where do you
put back in the game back in the game
baby let's go who's number two I'm
Number Two think I'm going to do this
big guy ooh that's a good slide it off
oo some kind of clothing should I open a
pizza blanket a pizza blanket Pizza
blanket want some help very
nice um I guess it's it's Pizza peoni
Pizza you know I could just eat you
up I'm three and I'm trying to think do
I want do I want that or the I think I
do oh
uhoh fast you can steal or open yeah you
Ste you steal a toilet light or can't
take this back you can have the toilet
light oh okay um I think I'm going to do
a new one all right okay you just like
the process of opening present
yes oh boy what is it wacky wavy
inflatable arm waving tube guy oh that's
fun like the on but yeah that's like
those things outside the gas stations
yes yes I'm going to take take what I
think might be sparklers it's not
sparklers it is an anal thermometer it's
a
lightsaber they are lightsaber
Chopsticks wow oh that's fun really
fun wait that's so fun yeah I want that
all right we got one that works one that
works another we got one working light
stable Chopstick and one that doesn't
I'm going to grab this guy oh that's a
good one we're such a nice family not a
lot of stealing looking at the toilet
like cuz I mean who doesn't want a
toilet like what you get Nicholas Cage n
that's a
best you do the other way and it turns
all
red oh I love that turns red I would
trade you two chops one working
Chopstick and one not working Chopstick
and then you expose his his eyes eyes oh
I like that then you can play who's the
pillow that's so funny that's so creepy
you know what what I think I'm going to
take this no I understand I think need
so does that mean I get one no you can
steal anything you want steal or even
can open right no I want to open you
want this no I don't I'm only interested
in the toilet light and I'm more
interested in opening present it feels
like a book oh oh hold on now those are
the sounds of someone who's upset with
their present no thermostatic cupw
warmer all right who was number one oh
that's kind of you get the last you're
the last one you get to you get to
decide to stick with everyone's gifts or
you can make swap or you can make a swap
I think I am going to stick with my
toilet light cuz that would be a very
fun thing to have okay who's really
happy with their gifts I'm pretty happy
really I'm really happy with my gift I
like a pizza blanket why not yeah I'm
happy with half of my gift I have to
attend to it otherwise it doesn't stand
it eventually just lays there like that
and you and it doesn't come back but if
you're ever selling your car
oh nice there you go he's not waving no
he's not one or the other wacky check us
out
[Music]
inas